a member of the local social democrats
and has a seat on the local council she
wants german politics to become more
diverse she was born in a german refugee
center
after her parents fled religious
persecution in pakistan
hibba
lives in the city of offenbach in
western germany over 60 percent of the
residents here have foreign roots or
their parents or grandparents did only
one in four holds german citizenship and
can vote on average they earn less than
non-immigrants and they tend to face
challenges in school and on the job
market hello
hi hi
the general election is on september
26th will you vote
may i ask which issues are most
important to you
the man answers in turkish
we are blue collar workers we want our
salaries to reflect price increases
groceries become more expensive so our
salaries should rise too you're going to
vote spday
very good
what is this
the conversations on the street continue
i grew up here i'm from
but i can't vote because i only have
turkish citizenship
yes it means decisions are made and you
have no say in them
i really think it sucks to be honest
what's your name
you say that
with a b
two b's
got it
over ten million people in germany are
not citizens that means they don't get
to vote in the september election
although they live work and pay taxes
here and those who can vote often don't
hibikowser says this year's election
campaign is partly to blame
the problem is that these people aren't
reached out to
it's rarely done
most tend to target certain groups of
people who they assume definitely have
the right to vote
they tend to approach white people
but they don't pay attention to people
who look like me for example
but when you talk to them you can tell
people are open to sharing what bothers
them
it's raining so the group takes a break
many here believe that racism can only
be overcome if german politics becomes
more open to immigrants
you contribute to society show
initiative and get politically involved
and people on the street tell you wow
you speak really good german
i can take that for a day or two but
it's really hurtful if people say that
to you every day
[Music]
i know what hip is talking about you're
being devalued just because you look
different
i've been in situations not in the
center of town though where people told
me i won't vote a foreigner like you
into parliament
nor causer has beaten the odds and holds
a seat in her city parliament now she
wants more people from minority or
immigrant backgrounds to get a voice in
germany's national parliament the
bundestag
you